low latency internet to people all over
earth
every one of these starlink missions
gets us closer to achieving that goal
some of the most exciting opportunities
for starlink are locations where
traditional fiber or
cable is simply not practical such as
rural and remote
communities it's also exciting for
places where fiber and cable are
impossible
such as aircrafts and cruise ships this
is a big endeavor
and we have a lot of work ahead of us
but today's launch gets us one step
closer
to these goals if you're interested in
getting future news about our startling
service
head on over to starlink.com and sign up
for updates
and if you're interested in helping roll
out starlink to the world our redmond
washington location which is just
outside of seattle
is looking for talented software
engineers the software engineers here at
spacex get to drive
work across exciting projects uh such as
our rockets
spacecrafts and satellites and ground
systems
send your resume to software jobs at
spacex.com
if you're interested in joining our team
so right now we are just under two and a
half minutes from liftoff
and falcon 9 is moving into the final
stages of the
countdown right now the first and second
stages are fully load
or nearly fully loaded with one million
pounds of kerosene fuel and liquid
oxygen
fuel is completely loaded locks on the
first stage is also completely loaded
and we are continuing to top off
the liquid oxygen loading on the second
stage
superchilled liquid oxygen which like i
mentioned we call locks
is our propellant oxidizer and that's
what is creating those white clouds
around the vehicle that you see there
this happens when liquid oxygen is is
exposed to ambient air which is warmer
and causes the liquid oxygen to
evaporate into gas and form those
white clouds the first stage should
finish prop loading
um here and actually i just noticed that
we
all all fuel tanks or and liquid oxygen
tanks are now fully loaded so
complete they're on the prop load
here in just 30 seconds or so we'll hear
a call out that falcon 9 is in startup
means that the rocket's autonomous
internal flight computers have taken
over the launch countdown
at t-minus two seconds the merlin
engines will light and liftoff will be
commanded to the vehicle at t minus
zero so right now as we approach the t
minus one minute mark the starlink
payload and the planet payloads continue
to look healthy
falcon 19 is tracking no issues on the
rocket weather continues to look good
and the range is green for launch falcon
9
stage 2 press perfect
lds go for lunch
minus 30 seconds
okay so we're in the final phases of the
countdown
starling satellites and sky stats one
two orbit
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
two one zero turn
and lift off to the top go starting
the successful liftoff of falcon 9 space
launch complex 40 for this 11th starlink
mission
the three planet sky sats and our 58
starling satellites are on their way to
space
about 10 seconds we will be approaching
max q
whirling engines are now going down as
they anticipate
the moment of greatest aerodynamic
pressure
max q all right
we just went through max-q and the
vehicle is now
supersonic and merlin engines have
throttled back up
so coming up in about a minute we'll
have three events happening back-to-back
first will be main engine cut off for
miko this is where all nine
merlin engines will shut off to slow the
vehicle down in preparation for the
second event
stage separation this is where the first
stage separates from the second stage
with stage one starting to make its way
back to earth for landing
while second stage will kick off the
third event in this sequence
scs-1 or second engine start one
this is where that merlin vacuum engine
will ignite
and begin to propel the second stage
along with our payloads
into orbit
main engine cut off coming up in about
20 seconds
everything continuing to look nominal
for stage one
yeah mikko stage separation confirmed
and in back ignition all right so there
we saw those three events all happen in
quick succession
stage one is now making its way back to
earth there on the left hand side of
your screen we can see the grid fins
slowly deploying
and on the right hand side of your
screen the merlin vacuum engine
beginning to develop that
healthy orange glow as it continues
it's journey on to orbit fairing
separation
confirmed we're just a few seconds away
from fairing deployment
there we go visual confirmation of
fairing deployment
we've once again as a reminder we flew
those fairings on a previous thrilling
mission
in january earlier this year
so with that we have successfully reused
this fairing pair
like i said earlier we will be
attempting to catch those fairing halves
with our recovery ships ms tree
and miss chief
bermuda acquisition continuing nominally
while the second stage is continuing to
do its job the first stage
is making its way back home to earth
in the next few minutes it will be
executing two burns
the first is the entry burn where three
of the merlin engines at the bottom of
the first stage
will light up and begin to slow the
stage down as it reenters the upper part
of the earth's atmosphere
the second burn is known as the landing
burn
this is a single engine burn
that will bring the vehicle speed down
rapidly
in order to make a soft landing on the
drone ship
the 58 starlink satellites that are
being carried along
on the right hand side of your screen
there by the second stage
we'll be joining our constellation of
over 600 starling satellites that are
already
on orbit which once again are designed
to provide high-speed low-latency
internet to people
on earth this is particularly important
for
places where good internet is hard to
access
as well as places where
wired or grounded internet is impossible
such as
ships and
airplanes we're one minute away from the
beginning of that entry burn
on the left hand side of your screen we
can see stage one coasting
using nothing but those grid fins we see
them articulate here and there as they
continue to steer
and we also utilize nitrogen gas
for occasional little bursts of that
nitrogen gas
and we use that for attitude control
which sometimes you can
catch a glimpse of as little white puffs
second stage continuing nominally
now at one and a half g's for
acceleration
and 10 seconds away now from the
beginning of that entry burn
again this is the first of two burns
intended to slow the vehicle's velocity
down as it re-enters the earth's
atmosphere
stage one entry burn startup
there we can see that the entry burn has
begun
and will last for about 20 seconds
stage two continues on nominal
trajectory again this burn utilizes
three engines at the base of the rocket
and then you can see the entry burn has
concluded
second stage trajectory is still looking
nominal
and in less than a minute we will see
the first stage on the left-hand side of
the screen perform its landing burn
looking back at our second stage
everything continues to look good
once again we are carrying 58 starlink
satellites
prepared to join the 600 over 600
starlink satellites that are already on
as well as
three rideshare satellites for our
customer
planets those three skysats
will join the 18 skysats
that are already also on orbit
we're about 15 seconds away from landing
burn
terminal guidance
stage one landing
and landing burn has begun
you should see the plume from the rocket
appear on the screen here
our touchdown and shutoff
successful landing of the first stage
booster
once again this is the sixth time that
we have utilized this booster
on a mission also marking its sixth
landing this is the of course i still
love you drown ship
in the atlantic ocean
so turning our attention back to second
stage we've had confirmation
of second engine cutoff or siko one
and we also have confirmation of a good
orbit so
now that stage two is going to coast in
this orbit
for another three and a half minutes
we're going to take a quick break
and we'll be back at t plus 12 minutes
for the deployment of planets
three skysats
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the webcast for this
11th starlink mission
we had an on-time liftoff from cape
canaveral
and everything is looking nominal for
our second stage
as we can see on our screen there the
stack of payloads
we are carrying 58 starlink satellites
as well as three rideshare satellites
for
our customer planet we're about 10
seconds away from the first of
three deployments for those planet sky
sets
skies at 21 deploy confirmed
okay deployment confirmed for that first
skysat
the first of three this morning
and there on your screen at the end of
the stack
slowly making its way away from the
second stage
we can see that first skysat moving
along
skysat 20 deploy confirmed
and confirmation that the second skysat
has deployed we'll
see that here momentarily ah there it is
at the
end of the stack again
and awaiting the third and final
deployment
for this rideshare customer
and sky's at 19 deploy confirmed
and deployment confirmed for that third
and final
sky sat for our customer planet
these three sky sats will be joining 18
already on orbit
which will complete the fleet of 21
and make it the largest high-resolution
fleet of satellites in orbit
to date like i mentioned before they'll
be capable of imaging a single location
up to 12 times a day
right now stage two is going to continue
to coast in this
orbit for a few more minutes during this
time
it will start to spin along its central
axis
which will give those startling
satellites the momentum they require
to space themselves out over time after
deployment
at t mi t plus 46 minutes
so right now we're going to take a break
but stay tuned because we'll be back
at t plus 45 minutes in preparation for
the deployment
of those 58 starlight starlink
satellites stay with us
you